[Music]
so you guys ever uh use venmo and you
pay somebody and you put like a little
joke memo i love it i say
sucking my dick off
for [ __ ] services yes four services the
funniest when you put when i paid
somebody anybody else got any paid me
let me see if i have anything for
exploring new adventures with a winky
face yeah yeah yeah
for your personality you know long time
i'm trying to see if i did have any but
i can't see right mine are probably so
hacky compared to ryan's i don't see any
now so he doesn't show me what i said
anyway um the main thing here is that
venmo
has been reporting
certain memos to the fbi
depending on what you say so don't write
sex services i don't know what i think
sex services you can do okay okay that's
cool all right cool i think it's okay
it's probably like drugs what you can't
do
is uh like this guy wrote isis
recruiting funds
and uh got his assets frozen oh
it's kind of a classic
but that's funny because isis would
never use that memo
they'd be like you know restaurant maybe
that's what they want you to think
yeah it's one of those ones okay so
let's do a little role play if you were
an isis what kind of uh memo would you
put sending it to if you're sending
money into a friend conversion fund
conversion fund they're gonna freeze
this video man there's some other things
that that got flagged like another guy
put uh for the release of the iranian
hostages in my basement
holy [ __ ] people are comedians i think i
put bribes for algerian border
guards and he got his [ __ ] frozen wow so
very geopolitical okay yeah that's what
gets your [ __ ] frozen
if you're mentioning other countries
hostage ransom this guy just put long
live cuba and got his [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's it
that's lame yeah for weeks you couldn't
use it
so who reported these venmo did or
maybe there's like a like an algorithm
that just likes pulls out
yeah i think what they'll do is that all
these people have the same exact thing
that happened where um there's their
venom got frozen they got a call
personally from um someone asking them
like what was that about and then they
just go it was a joke sorry well then
like a few weeks pass and they can use
it again
but then the isis the guy put the isis
thing um
venom reported that to the fbi fbi froze
bank accounts and he goes yeah it was
for isis funds
i thought it says it yeah it says it in
the memo dude that's what i said
why are you calling me about it can you
unfreeze my [ __ ] next tax reporting's
gonna be for 2022. oh my god not only
crypto nfts and stupid like yeah venmo
cash apps and then with people [ __ ]
making all of these things on the
receipts like ransom money whatever
right and then so now in the future
[ __ ] cpa they're gonna have to return
like do these tax returns with like so
what is [ __ ] coin
like you bought twenty thousand dollars
of
[ __ ] coin
and tommy's come talking
there's like some funny names there are
so it's it's even sadder that uh there
was like an american journalist working
in syria and he actually wrote syria in
his uh venmo memo when he was paying
somebody and he she got frozen for that
so he was in syria
that's such a bad system such a waste
though because you should put should put
like for butthole eating services or
something yeah because that's all good
yeah the government's not freezing those
these ones were flagged and then these
was warrant so you have uh words like uh
for some reason cuban sandwich gets a
flag because it's the word cuban so
maybe cuba is just a flag word damascus
steel gets flagged the mask is steel kkk
doesn't whoa hitman doesn't and neither
does bomb that's weird why cuba what's
going on that we don't know what if i
put china what's up with these
sandwiches
what's all these sandwiches where are
these cuban sandwiches are you a fan of
cuban sandwiches so i think that's a
it's almost like a psa that anybody
who's putting joke memos because
we try right now use bomb kkk and your
gucci
yeah
i don't know i got money in there
happy ending honestly if you did put
happy ending you put you probably should
put hooker it'll be fine but then i
think it's more like [ __ ] it's more like
foreign relations based [ __ ] that's even
worse yeah so what about
how about like iranian [ __ ]
that'll get you flagged if he even has
iran you'll be flagged you can't even
put iran yeah what if i say bomb hitler
tacos probably gonna be fine honestly
yeah because
that's true
but like
north korean massage well that you might
get flagged not for the massage
what if i put taiwan is a country do you
remember when um you already this video
is going to take
[Laughter]
like this is slightly off topic but
might as well be addressed do you
remember when mountain dew had that
contest to see what they were going to
name their new flavor yeah and they left
it up to the internet it's like in the
early 2000s so they did this contest
they were like anyone could submit any
name for a new flavor we will just let
everyone vote and then whatever the top
one is we're gonna make that the flavor
you know it was number one and number
two [ __ ] well they tried but no number
one was gushing granny
number two was hitler did nothing wrong
oh my god what would that flavor be
that'd be the
opportunity to just draw such a bad idea
wow i i'm into gushing grannies i think
because grannies could be a good does
that mean like everybody collectively
came up with that on their own or were
these choices because they were a bunch
of they're yeah they were a bunch of
submitted they were a bunch of submitted
choices that like 4chan just [ __ ]
destroyed it gushing grainy grape could
be could be pretty good let me let me
read you guys let me read you all of
them i mixed them up number one was
hitler did nothing wrong okay number two
is gushing granny number three's fapple
number four is diabetes
number five is gushing granny again wow
popular well it's probably the end
versus the g right yeah yeah yeah the
apostrophe yeah
number six is granny squirt number seven
is gushing grannies
number eight is gushing granny
number nine's fabulous apple
followed by gushing green granite so
no no there's no legit entries what do
they end up doing they canceled they
[ __ ] up they said you just [ __ ] it
up yeah just pick the one all the way
down that's not that bad there is one
that wasn't that bad i mean after you
got to go through moist nuggets sour
granny slap you get to meeny greeny that
was probably the only one that was like
sort of green yeah meany greeny and then
right after that granny mist
granny's that's good
that's good
that's not that bad either no that's
better than a gushing granny yeah oh my
god
and think of granny's watching this
she's like what's wrong with me
it's only grannies who voted
yeah yeah they're like
can't i have anything
no flavors named after us
you would think i mean like
in an age like that they were like okay
you guys [ __ ] it up what a joke
now it's like you joke around and it's
like are you joking yeah don't you
really have these thoughts though
so annoying okay are you sure you want
to tell a joke yeah you sure you want to
do that
because the penalty is just like if you
were telling the truth
back of the head bad boy
try it try it yeah it's rough man you
know like people just didn't people
didn't just disappear right there's the
same people that were laughing at it
today they're just like ashamed to laugh
at it now you know what a lot of the uh
reasons are now it's because oh i've
matured
i used to laugh at it because i didn't
know any better but now i'm more mature
i don't laugh at it
and i'm like bro you stupid you lost
life that's a very good responsibility
you're stupid
i'm mature you stupid that's my response
to everything yeah so you know if you're
if you're playing with venmo be careful
with the memos for now until like you
know the jokes become very clear until
this ball is over yeah no geopolitical
stuff maybe you could go on cash app
they don't care maybe zell was nicer
about that too yeah
on the memo would you go from bank to
bank
that's even more sketchy
you know on the wire you could send a
memo to the person and the bank
so it's separate yeah when you do it
when you do a transfer there's one for
the bank and then there's one that says
that's the funny one and this is the
business what if you mix it up
the bank would understand
like these guys are funny whoever these
guys are
he's like these dude check these out
check out these like doing the domino's
special order thing when you ask them to
do something random oh yeah you ever
seen those well did they make a letter
out of pepperoni people started making
jokes in those when they'd be like uh if
you had any special requests and you
could say things like flip i don't know
every other slice upside down and they
would just some of them would do it just
you know to appease you because they
play along
and then they would start doing really
advanced stuff and you know depending on
who you get right they might do it yeah
that was fun this makes your job more
interesting sure yeah but then if you i
mean if you said anything that had to do
with iran or taliban yeah i'm probably
gonna get rewarded my friend made my
pizza pizza right and i was like so what
is the most weirdest [ __ ] in the
toppings and the things that they've
asked for and they go there's this guy
that always came in and he wanted the
pizza
with no toppings and i'm like
so what it's just cheese pizza and he
goes no like
just the yeah just the baked
pizza that's it just the box
just the pasta the [ __ ] stock so he
wants it the way like bubbly shells hit
in the [ __ ] fridge yeah he wants to
make his own pizza huh
bubble leaves the crust right
i've never ordered one have you tried
doing that the bubbly it's i've seen it
and i'm like how does that thing stay
fresh it's
vacuum packed [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's like then he would come
in and he just orders just the pizza
just like bread baked pizza oh it's
funny that's so fitting that like a lot
of the time the weirdest thing people
order is really just the absence of
things rather than like yeah
accessibility
right right
that's probably the creepier thing
because then you just like give me a hot
dog hold the buns
just hold the hot dog
yeah just hold the hot dog
that's like some eric audrey [ __ ] like
he'll just go up to a [ __ ] thing yo i
i remember my brother took me a mexican
restaurant right and i was with his
buddies and then like um um i smoked
weed and then and then a little high so
we were just sitting there and i was
ordering and he was getting frustrated
with me and then i was like all right
[ __ ] i'll order and i said can i get a
quesadilla
meat quesadilla with no cheese because
i'm allergic i i don't i have i'm
lactose and he almost kicked my ass
because he was like why the [ __ ] did you
order quesadilla with no cheese and i'm
like why oh it's a quesadilla it's
supposed to have cheese
quesa yeah queso yeah i know but i was
high
that makes sense god yeah that is kind
of weird right because i was like oh
wait yeah maybe i'll get a taco then
question it's gonna be my ass cause i
didn't order cheese in my quesadilla
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you